who did Sabrina Carpenter play in Harry
Potter great question I was wrong so it
was a great experience and I like grew
up on that set yeah I'm a huge huge
potterhead I went to actually was
performing close to Universal in Florida
and went to Harry Potter World for the
day and I went into the room where they
like choose your wand for you like it's
a very like big moment that one was
chosen for me and then I brought it home
and now I cast spells on everybody it's
great who did Sabrina Carpenter voice in
Phineas and Ferb I was just like a small
like guest role I like went in for the
day and it was kind of like one of my
first voiceover jobs where they just had
me do like a bunch of like random voices
so I literally don't even remember who I
would have even played but there's like
throughout a few different episodes like
me just says like random guest things
that they would need like a little girl
like screaming or crying or random stuff
that they use all the time so I have no
idea if you found it let me know